good morning millennials
welcome back to the toast and happy
Thursday along awaited Thursday some
might say hello Jacqueline how are you
doing I'm doing well thank you yes it is
Thursday if you listen to yesterday's
episode we were hopeful that it would be
Thursday and today and if you didn't if
you didn't listen to yesterday's episode
are you okay well maybe they're just so
busy in love you know
things in a whirlwind that's nice that's
the only it's the only acceptable reason
to miss the toast is if you're in love
yes if you're in love yeah I agree or
what are other acceptable reasons
death like you died oh you died yeah or
but you better be listening you know
it's their afterlife if there was a
death like you know in in your world you
should still listen because we're here
to lift you up it's true I honestly as
you know anyone who's dealt with grief
knows that one of the best ways to just
kind of take yourself out of it
momentarily is to distract yourself and
what is more distracting than two
insanely gorgeous girls being hysterical
yeah laughter is the best medicine it
really is so so I'm a doctor
uh if you're consider me a doctor I
guess another excuse would be like if
you like are in the hospital or
something but again you can bring your
phone to the hospital yeah we're like
there's a lot of waiting time we're here
for you
yeah I guess like the really truly only
excuse is like if you're just out living
life so hard that's what we want for our
girlies like we want you to go Thrive so
if you're just having too much fun or
you're too in love or you're on like a
fabulous trip only acceptable reason to
not listen to the toast yeah and it's
and it's temporary you know of course
so if you're back and you missed
yesterday's episode we missed you we
have a lot of story not a lot of stories
but some of the stories like we will be
discussing themes from the week
so you're saying it's going to be a
rather thematic episode yeah I mean I
think actually this isn't a joke every
episode we do is very thematic like
there's this there's a thread that is
woven through each episode
unintentionally where like at the start
of the episode we're talking about
something and by the end of the episode
we bring it back to that theme I believe
that's what like a moral of the story is
there's like a moral of every episode
yeah but there's also just a Common
Thread
comments and invisible would you say an
invisible string yes
that's exactly what it is is that like
our theme song
maybe for today
we'll see we'll see let the chips and
the words fall where they may
one of my favorite things to do is
definitely just like let the chips fall
where they may yeah
and that's what I strike slabs when I
let the chips follow where they may
because he gets to lick up all the
crumbs
I asked you like how you were doing now
I want you to ask me how I'm doing
Claudia how are you horrible
I know horrible what's going on
over the last two days I've been reading
the Nightingale which is a historical
fiction book about World War II and
yesterday I read like the final 40 which
is like where it all goes down
and when I tell you I was so
I don't there's not even a word like
bereft
so sad when the book ended not because
the book was over that happens to me
sometimes where I just loved the book
and I wanted it to keep going because
the contents of the book made me so
unbelievably sad that I was inconsolable
like the book was done and I was just
laying in bed crying and Ben was like
are you okay
and I was afraid to go to sleep because
I like couldn't stop thinking about the
book the book is about like Nazis and it
was just like I know I'm like the last
person on the planet to read this book
so me recommending it is like futile but
please like read this book it's not as
futile as people who recommend Verity
and the Seven husbands of Evelyn here
though so true
I love seeing that like people like by
the way and that was literally me I'm
like you guys have to read this book
girl we read this book five [__]
years ago yeah everybody has read the
book If you read books you've read these
books so funny so in my book love my
friend Abe who like I got really into
reading and we were like you know the
two kind of founding members of the book
club he the book that like changed his
life like for me it was luckiest girl
alive for him it was Verity and he's
like still always talking about variety
I'm like hey like get with the program
nobody like talks about Verity anymore
no and it's like the more you read the
more you're like embarrassed to talk
about Verity no not not embarrassed not
at all I feel like the more you read if
I now sat down and read some of my
favorite books they probably wouldn't be
my favorite book oh that's true too they
might not hold up but like anything
impresses you when you haven't read like
a good book in so long and now you see
there are so many good books and even
better books but no like now
having read so many books like I'm not
talking about Verity because it's just
like
so obvious
and the Nightingale is a book that a lot
of people recommend if you're in the
historical fiction World which not
everyone is but I think why the
Nightingale is so great it's because you
don't have to be obsessed with
historical fiction like me to enjoy it
and consume it and I think everyone
should read it I agree with you let me
tell you why the Nightingale is so good
and I'm like I kind of expose myself
hard here like of course I know about
World War II for the most part like I
know about the war from my own
experience which is the experience of
the Jews so like whenever I think about
World War II or the Holocaust like I'm
of course thinking about the Six Million
Jews the camps the gas Chambers like all
of that
um so there's like a lot of like
elements about the actual War part like
the allies and everything that I can't
lie I don't know like a [__] ton about
like not me no not knowing up until I
read this book that France just like
surrendered like the day the war started
and let the Nazis take over all of
France and all these people innocent
people just like living in Nazi
occupation not me not knowing that so
then it's like it added another element
to me like of course I know the
atrocities of the Nazis but like I
didn't know what they did to non-jews
just like living in the day life of War
right and like starving all these people
for years like they were all
malnourished they were all like
literally Skin and Bones by the end of
the war so many people died after the
war from just causes of the war yeah so
I just I learned so much about the
actual like landscape of the war like
when I read the rose code I learned
about the British part I didn't know
about that either this book was very
much like the French experience and
they're so different actually it's
actually good that you read one of them
because the French like they said they
had their front line of defense which
fell in like a matter of days and then
they were like here take half the
country and set up your own government
no not the French being hella losery I
did not know that yeah hello losery and
the British fought tooth and nail to
keep the Nazis off their Shores no and
like recruited everyone women men
children to contribute and you saw
Dunkirk didn't you
okay so I saw Dunkirk like not me
literally not knowing what Normandy was
like I kind of feel stupid
um you're putting the pieces together
every book or movie is like a piece of
the puzzle D-Day like Normandy like if
you would have asked me a year ago or
even like yeah if you would have asked
me like a month ago I'd be like
normandy's definitely Giving World War
One
yeah you think a lot of things are World
War one yeah you so when I finished a
book I call Jackie and I'm like
telling her like kind of sharing this
embarrassing thing that like I low-key
know very little about history and she's
like just wait till you hear about Japan
and I'm like oh World War One like Pearl
Harbor Hiroshima all of that she's like
that's World War II not me not knowing
that right so like the hell happened in
World War One
was kind it was the Germans versus
um
the rest of like Europe again the same
the same players and then the US comes
in
but it was kind of like the pre-game to
World War II yeah yeah and then I guess
like those beefs were never squashed and
like the reparations that Jeremy had to
like
pay for what they did in World War one
which was so horrible people think that
like that caused them to be even angrier
and go even inspired for World War II
and also like left it open for someone
like Hitler to come in and be like we
deserve better as Germans
the way like I know this is not a hot
take I [__] hate Nazis this book just
like reignited I feel like we talk about
the Holocaust like a lot on the podcast
and I talk about it as just like a
Jewish woman in my everyday life I do
um and when I feel like when we talk
about it now we talk about it like in a
very historical way like we feel very
far removed from it but this book was
just like such a stark reminder like
that this should actually happen it's
not just like in a textbook and I feel
like she did such an amazing job and I
actually asked you if she was Jewish
because I felt like she actually really
understood the Jewish Vibe if you know
what I mean like she didn't sound like
she was cosplaying Jewish characters
like it felt authentic but her two main
characters are not Jewish women no but
the parts about the Jews like her
neighbor and then just like what was
happening to the Jews and why they had
to you know send the boy back whatever I
just felt like I didn't feel like I was
being it wasn't feel like LARPing you
know appropriation I guess the word
would be but I just thought she was so
she's such a talented like the way I
felt after reading this book Jackie I
sent her a message on Instagram like a
[__] break I was like I know I'm the
last person on the planet to read this
book but I just read it like thank you
for writing it you're incredible like I
love you she didn't answer or open it
but I just felt like you know she needed
to hear it this book was just a feat it
was magnificent like I can't say enough
about this book and my friend who
recommended it from my book club Natalie
she was like the first like 70 pages are
like confusing and they're just like
setting the scene so don't give up I'm
like okay because I was like At first
this book stings yeah she's just like
having a baguette in the field like
saying better yeah
yeah and it's like all right let's get
to it let's get to it and it took me in
a like a direction I did not even
I just I can't say enough words about
this book and I'm like being one of
those people the book like was popular
five years ago I love this book
everybody needs to read it it was the
most amazing book I could not stop
crying and then you delivered the most
amazing news to me that there's actually
a movie being made out of it the story
The the book is about two sisters and
you actually told me even more fun fact
that the two sisters have been cast and
they're cast by actresses who are
sisters who are if you guys want to know
the uh Dakota and Elle Fanning are
supposed to play the sisters but Claudia
and I did some research into it and the
movie's still in pre-production they're
the only ones who have been cast I don't
think anything has happened to move the
needle on the movie and especially now
with the strike and everything
I don't know if we're ever getting this
movie it was supposed to come out
December 2022.
right which is like nine months ago
right and that didn't happen I would
love if it did I think it would be great
and I think though Fanning sisters would
be great no like they're legit actresses
you know they would make the movie feel
like a real movie yes they really would
this episode of the toast brought to you
by
becoming a mom has come with a lot of
big changes and I'm getting ready to
experience some of that all over again
some of the joys and wonders of
postpartum life that you no one tells
you about that you know a lot of us have
to learn the hard way but something
super common that we don't always talk
about when it comes to postpartum life
is bladder leaks one in two women over
20 experience bladder leagues and most
young moms try to use period pads to
solve the problem you know you think
that makes sense but actually period
pads are not designed for peeing
thankfully Poise Ultra thins are
specifically designed for bladder leaks
and keep you 10 times drier than the
leading period pad so for my mamas out
there for my new mamas this one is a pro
tip for you because
you gotta have the right Goods when you
need them the Clean dry and fresh
protection these pads provide is a
lifesaver and they're shaped to fit and
flex with your body so you can stay
comfortable and live without compromise
Poise Ultra thins offer with and without
wings so you can live
worry free and you know free of worries
of bladder leaks not having the right
pads not having what you need when you
need it personally I have enough on my
plate as a mom so I love the idea of
taking one worry off of the list it
takes Poise learn more about Poise Ultra
Thins and how they're specifically
designed for bladder leaks at poise.com
today's episode of the toast is brought
to you by Lands End anyone can slap a
logo on a boring generic shirt but with
Lands End Business you can get made to
order uniforms that become a part of
your brand get fully customized clothes
accessories and promotional products
featuring your logo and colors all made
by the expert team at Land's End and
with the best in-class customer care let
Lands End handle the inventory while you
just run your business you guys know
uniforms merch really can be an
extension of your brand and lens end is
a great resource for your business they
have quality comfort and style that you
can count on since 1993 thousands of
businesses have relied on lands and
business to outfit their employees they
offer timeless style that fits every
body type with the widest range of sizes
in branded apparel you can see your logo
in Vivid colors on t-shirts outerwear
hats mugs water bottles and more
hundreds of products perfect for any
trade show event or holiday gift Lands
End Business is the leading online
supplier of iconic uniforms for everyone
whether you're a carpet cleaner mechanic
moving company or a corner Pizza Shop
they have your uniform needs covered
it's so much more than the same old work
polos you can get customized uniforms
that fit the way you work and keep your
employees cool dry and comfortable you
can get email chat and phone support
from their customer service team who are
eager to help every business is treated
like a VIP whether you have five
employees or 50. so see why thousands of
companies count on Lands End Business go
to
business.landsend.com toast and use
promo code toast for 20 off your order
that's
business.lands end.com slash toast promo
code toast for 20 off your order
so that was just like ruined my night
like I was inconsolable I couldn't like
focus on young Sheldon I needed to just
go to sleep but I was so afraid to go to
sleep because I was just you know when
you finish a book you're like in the
book in the book oh my God what these
days whatever content I'm consuming it
takes up my whole night like my like all
of my thoughts and dreams like are just
about whatever it is whether it's
sometimes it's a song Sometimes It's a
book or a movie like it's always just
about this thing it's so annoying so are
you saying basically last night that you
dreamed about 80 for Brady
no but last night Zach and I watched
well Zach watch because I was trying to
read my book and he was looking for a
movie and he put on 80 for Brady and
always when he puts something on like I
wind up giving an e of course and then I
was like you know what I'll just I'll
just watch the movie like I can read my
book before I go to sleep now what what
um inspired Zach to choose that film he
loves football and he loves like a good
corny movie I think it's something that
he does like you know probably saw
commercials for him was like oh maybe I
would see that one day and our day came
yesterday
and the movie was so ridiculous but the
thing that kept getting me through was
like this is inspired by a true story so
it's just about like four
senior women who love Tom Brady and love
the Patriots and they're gonna go to the
Super Bowl in 2017 to finally like see
their team play and I'm like that is so
cute like what happens at the Super Bowl
that this is a movie that was made about
these women so the whole time I'm like
really just wanting to know how it ends
the fact that this was a story worth
telling the movie did you know what the
results of the 2017 Super Bowl were yes
I actually remember that Super Bowl
because it was so crazy that was the one
where they played the Falcons and they
were losing the entire time do you
remember it was Lady Gaga's halftime
show but I didn't remember that I
remember I didn't remember her being at
that particular game but they were
losing the whole time in the fourth
quarter like down by 20 something points
and in the fourth quarter they made it
all back and they won it was a really
crazy Super Bowl so
I was like what what's the story here
and the movie is preposterous it's like
so bad and they're doing all these crazy
ridiculous things and at one point the
women sneak into the like control room
to talk to Brady in his ear to like give
him a pep talk yeah what I'm like I
don't believe you I'm like oh is that
the crazy thing that like makes this a
movie so after we finish the movie I
like Google it and no none of these
things happen it's just like these four
senior women who love Tom Brady it's
just like about them but the whole movie
is like made up and it's that is a [__]
movie like that get made but the
Nightingale was still in pre-production
I have no idea and what's even crazier
is that Tom Brady he produced this movie
it was the first movie from his
production company and like
what a weird [__] choice because it's
like all about him like they're the one
of the main characters is like you know
going through it and like every time
she's struggling like Tom Brady's like
talks to her you're kidding no like
she's a Tom Brady bobble head and like
he will say some words like oh yeah wait
is Tom in the movie yes he makes like a
cameos one they use footage from the
game but then after the game the women
get to go back to the locker room like
it's just ridiculous and Julian Edelman
is in it for a second Gronk and Danny
Amendola
okay wait I'm not okay this is so dumb
and to be honest like his production
company this being like their first
release like that's like really like
egotistical no so egotistical and I said
to Zack now I know why he won't retire
because he can't do anything else
in the world all those resources like
pick a book any book turn it into a
movie and you choose this like
what and and you're making up this
Preposterous story none of these things
happened
no and like Jane Fonda should know
better oh my God it was ridiculous who
were the other four women the actors did
you know any of them Rita Moreno love
Sally Field my birthday buddy oh yes I
remember them all doing press together I
think they were on watch Happens Live or
something and I think the four
her name
Candace Bergen no but she would have
been no it's confusing because Jane
Fonda also does these other movies
called book club there's like a sequel
where it's for senior women and it's
like the mom from stepmoms I think it's
Candice Bergen's baby in that one Jane
Fonda this is Lily Tomlin oh yes and is
she also in that show with Jane Fonda
Grace yes and Frankie that's what I
thought but I didn't want to just like
assume they're all in the same shows but
they are
yeah yeah no it's like this core group
of senior women just out here working
and so while Jane Fonda should have
known better
certainly Sally Field should have known
better
it was so there were so many celebrity
cameos that were just like
so weird also do you know Guy Fieri's
name is like pronounced Guy Fieri
yes I I like I do know that he's a
really big part of the movie and they're
always like looking for Guy Fieri
because like I don't want to spoil it
but they're like Mr fiatti Mr Vietti I'm
like
Fieri it's giving like French but no guy
is not French he's an All-American man
yeah so it was so insane I had to see it
through till the end and it was shocking
no I'm glad you did the good news is I
slept like a baby probably because it
was so mindless
I have nothing on my mind after that
that's that's actually the exact type of
thing you should be watching before bed
like mindlessness it's true and then I
continued to read my book I posted about
this on my Instagram I'm reading this
book apparently it's called trophy wife
and the cover is like some thought on a
balcony sexy lady the book that I am
reading the inside of the book and now
I'm at like 30 percent
has nothing first of all the protagonist
is a man has nothing to do with the
cover or the title I think it's
mislabeled but I don't know get yourself
a refund girlfriend no I'm liking the
book I have I'll wait till I get to 100
to see but like there's not even a high
rise in the book like if they're in
London he just bought like a country
house why is she on a balcony in West
Hollywood
you have 70 like maybe it will come full
circle to the title but I'm really
enjoying it but I don't want to
recommend trophy wife yet because you
might not get the same book I'm reading
right there's clearly like a clerical
issue over at amazon.com I really really
wonder if there is
wait let me why don't you just Google it
trophy wife and book okay and look at
the description yeah there's a sexy lady
on it okay what does it say the book's
about
okay
the brilliant new psychological Thriller
a wonderful book his prized possession
his greatest mistake from The Moment I
Saw Anne I knew she was perfect for me
okay Dan fine is that it yeah even
though from the moment he saw her he did
not think he didn't even look at her but
I've actually I never read a book that
the main character is a man
and you probably haven't read very many
but you've read some like what
I've also like I don't think I ever read
except the silent patient that was the
only book in the last
two years three years that I've read by
a man I like don't [__] with men I know
it's really funny how like every book I
read is a female author books are for
the girl so like unless it's like you
know James Patterson
yeah I guess Alex like they're that
whole genre but the kind of stuff we
want to read like yeah it has to be
written by women yeah I'm so not
interested in like reading the male
perspective yeah but then I also think
that sometimes like women when they
write men they're so off
yeah but that's the part that's fun
about it is that you're writing like
from the female perspective the ideal
man that's why it's like you know it's
fiction yeah yeah it's fiction but it's
so unrealistic it's like not fun
oh I disagree it's so unrealistic it's
actually fun no like these men that like
Colleen Hoover writes like they don't
exist no they don't but that's why these
books are so popular
so true and with like the Resurgence of
reading in the last few years like
Reese's book club and you know talk talk
it's really becoming like it's a female
thing yeah I I agree I also think
there's now this new energy amongst
female readers whereas like male readers
have are pretty constant like they like
their history books by like men have
been read not that women don't read but
I feel like so you literally sound like
them
no I don't but that this Resurgence of
like Reese's book club book talk it's
all books for women yeah so the The
Surge has been for the girls
and by the girls and by the girls yeah
exactly like the men have their literary
corner
established already
yeah yeah and ours is not a corner it's
like more of like a wing in our own
little corner and I will say the one
book that I read by a man the silent
patient I thought was the worst most
overrated book so I don't know I don't
know what that says about man man
writers yeah no the few books that I
have read by men have been really good
but that's because they're like the
cream of the cream of course from the
men reading the good ones yeah it would
be like if boys only read like The
Nightingale luckiest girl alive
we've been talking about books for about
20 minutes and it's the first Thursday
in August that was my next segue new
episode of the redheads just dropped
you guys this month's book was so good
spoiler alert all four of us really
liked it some more than others but there
was not a dissenter in the group so if
you're looking for a book to read I
would really recommend I could live here
forever by Hannah Halperin some of the
redheads were crying upon reading the
book like it's a book about love and
heartbreak and addiction and it just hit
everyone differently but it was so good
the episode was great and it was our
last episode before my one month
maternity leave which we also need to
discuss today on the episode we'll
discuss my toast maternity leave but
redheads will be back first Thursday of
October with a snitch you're only
skipping one month only skipping one
month snitch's choice is coming up and
we are reading the fourth Wing by
Rebecca yaros because that book is
everywhere and it's getting like just
such positive reviews in a different way
than like other books got it it seems
like there's a lot there so I'm so
excited to read that I think all of us
are bummed we have to wait two months to
read it but I'm really excited that it's
gonna be a redheads book
well you deserve the month off from you
know putting the literary community on
your back thank you but having said that
we need to discuss your maternity leave
you know it's all been very up in the
air but we're down to the wire now we're
down to the wire and my maternity leave
starts after tomorrow's show so tomorrow
is the last episode of the toast before
maternity leave
and so that means that we will have four
weeks of no toast so August 4th is our
last episode and we return September 5th
right after Labor Day we know it'll be
tough for you guys but you know what
hopefully we can do about it and you
weren't listening anyway and if and if
you're not in love maybe use those four
weeks to find love Yeah and we're I'm
excited for when we come back it's gonna
be really awesome I'm excited for the
time off excited for all the changes in
the next month
um no you take all the time off you need
when we return September 5th Jackie will
come as much as she will be a flat can
Flex schedule it'll be a hybrid we have
uh Ben Taylor snitch a bunch of new
co-hosts that I've been talking to who
love the toast so it'll be just like I
feel like everybody loves maternity
leave the last time we have nothing to
be afraid of this isn't our first rodeo
you know last time we were like a little
nervous we never did it before now we've
done it it was a great time Jax came and
just blew everyone away like once a week
and then the other episodes were like
fun guests I might do some solo episodes
patreon will still be active for this
month so if you're
gonna suffer August without your regular
toast episodes I recommend signing up
for patreon patreon.com toast you'll get
five episodes for the month of August
that we will release during the
maternity leave they will be we have
pre-recorded some jockey stuff I will be
doing Vlogs and and patreon podcast
episodes so we'll take care of you don't
worry like just everyone stay calm you
know yeah no it's gonna be great
patreon's always there for you and if
you're not a patron already and you sign
up today you will have enough episodes
to get you through till the end of the
year so
um those people who haven't listened to
all the patreon episodes yet like really
it's all waiting for you and for
everyone else you'll at least be covered
more than once a week with
podcasts and blogs that we have
forthcoming
now I just think I speak for everyone
when I say like thank you for going this
far with us I could never be me you're
setting an incredibly bad precedent for
when I'm pregnant because like [__]
when I hit six months I'm out like
goodbye don't talk to me so you're
setting unrealistic expectations for
women again
um but we so appreciate all the work
that you've done this is I know been a
treacherous few months for you and you
gave your all to the toast and we really
really appreciated the community
appreciates you thank you and we
appreciate you for holding it down in
those days when I couldn't give it so
it's been
a really crazy journey and thank you to
all the toasters for just coming along
with us listen to every episode we see
all the numbers and everyone's just
stuck by us through all the changes it's
true and it's true the videoless
episodes whatever it is
so I'm excited everyone's just been like
shucking and jiving with us like
whatever we say is going down they're
like okay I'll be there yeah so it's
been great and I'm so glad that we've
come this far I'm excited to start my
time off God is good Baruch Hashem God
is good yeah and also when I come back
this maternity leave like when I come
back will be a little different because
the studio in my house I can probably do
more than I could yeah last time having
to go to the studio it's so true so we
shall see not to make everything about
me but I have started once again I feel
like everyone's tired I'm The Girl Who
Cried apartment I am looking to move and
everyone knows I live in a bunker with
no light and I'm like on this journey to
seeing the snow by Christmas and
yesterday we officially started our
journey looking for apartments
everything we saw yesterday was
unbelievably trashy and overpriced
um today I'm seeing an apartment like
you know when you have a feeling like it
might be the one yeah
the one I'm seeing today like might be
the one and what's so exciting about it
is that it has like this like this is
unheard of in New York it has a pantry
it's like literally like a big ass
walk-in closet that's like for food it's
right off the kitchen
um but it has no shelves or anything in
it it's just like a blank white room and
I could literally make my own Studio at
home so like you know if I'm sick or you
know Ben is always recording good guys
at like the middle of the night like I
could have my own little like home
office and I would be just like you like
with my own little except I wouldn't
have flamingos I would just have the
leaves I think like I'm really excited
about it I need this apartment to work
and it's like actually decently priced
when do you see it which makes 145 today
which just makes me think like it's
decently priced like all the photos are
fake I'm so sick of everyone doing that
like everything is [__] fake online
Street Easy like they render these
photos like I understand rendering a
photo of an apartment like putting a
couch and a bed in there these real
estate agents are getting crafty with
their renderings like they'll render the
window so if the window which a lot of
apartments in New York do looks at a
brick wall nobody wants that they'll put
a fake City skyline in and it's only
until you literally walk in the door
that you see this apartment has no light
because it stares at another building
like they are doing the Chris they're
changing the floors like oh look at
these dark mahogany wood floors you get
in these are old ass parquet floors like
they're lying to you it should be
illegal like where is the legislation
I don't know sis
it's so annoying well I hope that it's
everything you wanted to be the pictures
didn't look that fake so no they didn't
so like everyone just prayed for me like
if this apartment works I will not only
see the snow by Christmas but I will
have like a home studio mini studio it
wouldn't be like miniature toast HQ no
because we know both it no but it's like
for you to work from home home but no
I'm just so so excited about it I'm
pumped for you yeah it's like kind of a
big day for me so everyone just like
sent me positive real estate energy will
do sending you positive real estate
energy thank you
so with that I do feel all caught up
on the happenings of you and I in the
last 24 hours me as well and now we need
to talk about the happenings of the
world others of others in the last 24
hours so without further Ado
it is time for the fast five stories
that you need to know
today's episode of the toast is brought
to you by game time buying tickets to
your favorite events should not be
stressful game time is the fast and easy
way to buy tickets for all the sports
music comedy and theater near you with
killer deals on last minute tickets and
their best price guaranteed you can stop
stressing over the tickets and start
getting hyped for the fun you're gonna
have I love having the game time app on
my phone at all times I live in New York
a fabulous City with fabulous events
going on at all times I also travel a
lot so it's always just a good thing to
have on my app if I'm in a new city and
I have nothing to do that night I pull
up the game time app I know I'm gonna
get a great deal and it's really helpful
in finding cool fun things to do whether
that's sports music comedy athletes you
know sports game time is the place for
last minute ticket deals no longer
having to plan months in advance game
time has deals on tickets right up to
the day of the event get exclusive Flash
Deals on tickets for football basketball
baseball concerts comedy theater and
more if you're scouring for era's
tickets this weekend I checked game time
before my New York shows and I found it
really helpful they had great deals it's
the fastest growing ticket app in the
country for a reason you're getting
image edges of your seats before you buy
so you know exactly what to expect when
you arrive you can buy tickets in a
matter of seconds it's literally two
Taps and you're all set and tickets are
sent directly to your phone so you never
have to dig through your email snag the
tickets without the stress with Game
Time download the game time app create
an account and use code toast for 20 off
your first purchase terms apply again
create an account and redeem code toast
for 20 off download game time today last
minute ticket deals lowest price and of
course it's guaranteed today's episode
of the toast is brought to you by Branch
Basics it's non-toxic it's
hypoallergenic it's free from fragrance
hormone disruptors and harmful
preservatives it's Branch basic our
favorite baby and pet safe cleaning
supplies so their premium starter kit
will provide you with everything you
need to replace all of your toxic
cleaning products in your home it's
really a no-brainer there are so many
reasons to love Branch basics of course
being baby and pet safe being non-toxic
I personally love it because it's not a
million products they use their
concentrate that you can use for all
different types of surfaces I live in an
apartment in New York City with not a
ton of storage Galore and I find that
Branch Basics products work work really
well and they don't take up a lot of
space in my cabinets also if you suffer
from eczema allergies or asthma make the
switch to Branch Basics and you will
notice a visible difference their refill
model is fabulous as well because once
you run out the only thing you need to
repurchase is that concentrate and the
oxygen boost and then you have all of
your products like it's really such a
genius model and of course you know
Jackie got into clean girl era when she
became pregnant
um there's really no downside to having
non-toxic cleaning products in your home
it's so much better for your babies for
your pets and brunch Basics best of all
is clean and cost effective so if you're
looking to save 15 off and get free
shipping on your starter kit use code
toast at branchbasics.com that's code
toast t-o-a-s-t you'll get 15 off plus
free shipping when you purchase that
starter kit the starter kit has
everything you can need you'll be so
happy that you switch it's easy it's
cost effective it's baby and pet safe
and of course it's non-toxic
great thank you Claudia our first story
lizzo is speaking out she's hitting back
at the outrageous unbelievable sexual
harassment lawsuit so lizzo posted a
multi-slide notes to her Instagram
talking about the bombshell lawsuit that
three of her former backup dancers filed
against her on Tuesday that has been the
Talk of the Town oh truly the talk of
the ton
she said
quote these last few days have been
gut-wrenchingly difficult and
overwhelmingly disappointing my work
ethic morals and respectfulness have
been questioned my character has been
criticized usually I choose not to
respond to false allegations but these
are as unbelievable as they sound and
too outrageous to not be addressed she
said the sensationalized claims came
from former employees who already
publicly admitted that their behavior
while touring with her had been
inappropriate and unprofessional she
explained that with her passion comes
hard work and hard high standards
admitting that she has had to make hard
decisions it's never my intention to
make anyone feel uncomfortable or like
they aren't valued as an important part
of my team but overall she's
categorically denying these allegations
saying she's not trying to be appear as
a victim but implored her fans and
followers to know that she is not the
villain that she has been portrayed as
in the recent days
so this response kind of gave nothing
um she didn't really address the biggest
claim which was you know the vagina
apple banana excuse me she did but she
said you know I've been open with my
sexuality but like
okay and that has nothing to do with
this yeah I mean I do think she's
Limited in what she can say and even her
saying something and just the overall
message is like I did not do this [__]
this is not who I am that's the ti she's
denying not that she would do anything
other than that if she was going to put
out a statement not be like yeah sorry
about that it was a Notes app screenshot
which I found shocking just given the
gravity of the situation what would you
have expected a video I know I don't
know there are many different forms or
just like to release a statement like on
a word doc or something like that the
notes app just it does in this culture
like diminish it's like kind of at this
point like a trope
yeah but a word doc you know what I mean
like people make statements that just
like look different
you mean would you like a PDF a cam boat
I wouldn't like to see anything I just
think it's interesting to know and worth
noting that it was a Notes app
screenshot got it
but that's where you go to write your
thoughts and feelings like when I have
something that I like I'm thinking I go
to my notes app
no I I totally get it I'm just I'm
mentioning it
what are her other options for real
I mean celebrities release statements
all the time on social media and they
take many different forms
colors you know layouts formats but
don't you think like then if it was a
color we would be like
this she's not taking it seriously yeah
yeah yeah no I'm just saying like I
think a lot of times people kind of shy
away from doing like a classic Notes app
apology because it's become kind of um
it's a classic you know yeah it's cliche
for a reason so true yeah I think what
whatever medium I think people maybe
expected something slightly more
official
okay but
um you don't have to keep arguing with
me about this you don't no yes and no
because her brand is so her and
especially her social media like if she
had put out something that really looked
like it was written by PR people I think
that would ring false
I mean it's such a serious thing it's
like an actual like I wouldn't be
surprised if like it looked like a legal
notice like it is a serious legal matter
yeah
it is
well
what do you think
I mean she didn't say anything so she
said she said which I would have
expected her to say like what did she
say no I did that [__] let me pay up
this lawsuit like
it's in her best interest financially
and you know publicly to deny it at this
current Junction she didn't say anything
she basically
I don't know for me like of course like
the kind of grotesque allegations are of
interest but what I find even more
interesting is like the people coming
out of the woodwork who have you know
very closely worked with her and there's
proof of that just saying she's a
horrible person yeah for me the most
interesting thing I mean of course
there's always going to be a pylon
there's always going to be people that
don't like you
that the fact that no one is coming
forward to say the opposite whether it's
people that's worked with her or so like
fellow Stars celebs you know she's one
of the most popular in the industry
people like she's always like collabing
and has so many friends it seems and
that no one has come forward to be like
this is not the lizzo that I know
wait and also you saw Tina Knowles
commented on an Instagram that was like
talking about Beyonce and she was
basically like oh my God you guys look
for something and everything she also
didn't say Kelly Rowland's name or her
sister's name so she basically put that
to bed
I don't know
and I'm suspicious for sure I don't know
if she did
oh you think she's out of bed I think
maybe maybe Beyonce took out other
people's names
so that's a lesson yeah to lesson it's
not just like I'm taking out Liz oh but
I want to take out lizzo so let me take
out the two people who I'm closest to so
they won't be offended Solange and Kelly
yeah yeah
no that's a good point I think that's
what it is so you think there's there
there I think there's there there but
she has plausible deniability by taking
out more than she does that's so true
not you being a lawyer yeah
um so yeah that's what's most shocking
to me that there's not like two camps
being like no lizzo is a great person
and she would never do these things and
then the other people who have are
disgruntled
that's actually a really good point
I guess we can wait and see if like
anybody does come forward but I don't
think anybody wants to throw themselves
in the middle of this like messy ass
thing
yeah well I mean for anyone who's oh and
by the way for anyone who's worked with
her who has positive experiences like
they really have nothing to lose
yeah by the way though I I could see
like if other celebrities came forward
and were like lizzo is fabulous that's
like the exact thing she's being accused
of like of course she would be nice to
Harry Styles but not people who she
considers beneath her that's like the
difference it's all people who work for
her got it yeah so and especially
because it wouldn't be helpful it would
actually fuel the fire we're not getting
any former current employees coming
forward being like no lizzo was the best
boss I ever had yeah Champions women
unrelated Theo is like actually 10 feet
for me 10 feet he's on the floor like
all the way over there I'm about to
vomit from the smell of this part like
that's power he's a powerful person he's
a powerful man
oh my God and he like keeps going it
smells horrible is he sick
it's giving sick energy
something funny it's lingering and
strengthening oh that's the worst kind
powerful l d
are you ready for our next story
I am have we said everything we need to
say about lizzo yeah I'm waiting to see
like you know
this has to play out in the court of law
obviously these allegations are
extremely incongruous to who she has
said that she is but she's maintaining
that she is who she is right and I will
wait and see
yeah but it's shocking stuff and I'm
sure one thing she did kind of address
is that she's like difficult to work
with and her
um rebuttal to that is like I'm
extremely passionate about my art like
yeah I'm hardcore I work hard that's
maybe not for everyone that was like the
only kind of direct allegation that she
addressed
I that's not what's bothering me that
she might be like a tough boss no like I
can see that there's an argument to be
made for like you know there's a lot at
stake it's a high stress environment
sure there's an argument there yeah yeah
so we'll see what um
what else comes out but our next Story
another thread from the week Taylor
Swift
so California politicians are urging
Taylor Swift to postpone her LA concerts
over the hotel strike days after
attending her show actually so these
California politicians pleaded with
Taylor to postpone the last leg of her
sold out aerostore in solidarity with
striking Hotel employees in La including
the state's lieutenant governor who
actually just went to her show at oh you
guys Stadium yeah
okay not only that but like so the
politicians want Taylor to fix the
strike not the politicians no it's so
crazy Twisted the union it represents
over 32 000 Hospitality workers in
Southern California and Arizona and they
are striking for higher wages because
like the cost of living has gone up and
then they need higher wages and it's
like Taylor canceling her show is Gonna
Save the car the uh cost of living
crisis and actually her fans who paid
for the hotels are not going to get
their money back they're going to be
stuck in L.A she's canceling her shows
because of a problem you caused and you
can solve I think it's like it's half a
million people who are currently have
tickets to see Taylor so putting all
those people in a bad financial
situation could cause a mini recession
like this is a terrible idea and this is
just the whole thing that's so [__]
with celebrity culture like anytime
there's like a you know a national
crisis or like an issue politically it's
always like Taylor Swift do something
she's a singer like what can she [__]
do no like the the 53 officials signed
the letter to Taylor asking her oh my
God
these literally why don't you go be
helpful why don't you negotiate the
hotel strike like why don't you go
actually do something and you know what
the pressure on hotels right now from
all the people who are gonna flock to La
starting literally today
they want to do they want to have the
most staff like they want to they don't
want to cancel reservations because they
don't have enough you know concierges or
hotel bellhops like if anything like
this big event is probably putting
pressure on them they're gonna lose
money if they can't fulfill the demand
so actually Taylor's probably helping
move the strike forward
yeah no but the the overall problem that
they are striking against which is cost
of living is a political issue a
political issue not a tailor issue yeah
literally this makes no [__] sense
it's so moronic like the fact that 53
politicians took time out of their day
to write a petition and sign in like you
know how to slow everything in
government it's like this is probably
like a week-long affair you know what
they could have done for the cost of
living crisis in a week yeah they
actually uh worked on it ridiculous
ridiculous I mean I don't think she's
going to postpone her shows no and
literally it would be so dumb like give
the hotel workers what they want like
nobody on the planet Works harder has to
deal with more [__] from people than
hotel workers and it's these huge
conglomerates like Marriott and just
give them what they [__] want and
leave Taylor alone the hotels would have
to be giving the hotel workers what they
want like yeah that's what I'm saying in
control of their wages none of the
politicians should work on affordable
working within their cities well they
should work on yes of course like the
economy they should also work on like
working with these huge Hotel groups
like Starwood I forget all the names but
they're all these huge conglomerates
like working with them helping the
strike move forward instead of like
literally working on this nonsense yeah
this is
it's honestly like embarrassing to think
about like these are people who are in
like control and power and they like
make the city Go Round And this is their
best solution you took the words right
out of my mouth this is embarrassing
yeah
and look I I saw this on Tick Tock a few
weeks ago I'm like oh my God this is so
dumb but like now it's an actual thing
because at first it was just like people
on social media being like Taylor do
something and now it's like actual
politicians I'm humiliated for this
country yeah humiliated she's doing
eight shows at La
I don't know she's doing a [__] [__]
ton that's crazy are you feeling fomo
no I mean I did have tickets that I did
give up because I wanted to be here with
you oh that's true I I do I feel good
about it like I've seen it three times
let someone else go you know and
actually she just posted on Instagram
while we were recording
um new U.S states I can read them to you
which is exciting for you because in
October she'll be in Miami for three
nights
so we'll go
then she has three nights in New Orleans
this happens yep oh no no sorry this is
2024. great even better then she has
three nights in Indiana Indianapolis
Indiana and then one two three four five
six nights in Toronto so we can go to
Toronto but you'll come to Miami oh 100
Margaret just put it in the family chat
and was like see you [__] in Miami no
this isn't an option Olivia oh my god
when the snitch is lit
knowing the snitch is
there's no coming between her yeah
today's episode of the toast is also
brought to you by eBay authenticity
guarantee you know it's no secret that
Jackie and I love to invest whether it's
in purses clothing or shoes Jackie more
specifically but me too you know I get
involved here and there and we are
always making sure to shop smart with
eBay authenticity guarantee eBay
authenticators are there verifying every
detail of your purchase eBay
authenticity guarantee protects buyers
from fakes gives them the assurance that
they're getting the real deal when
you're spending a lot of time investing
online you know there's so many people
out there who might not have the best of
intentions and eBay is out here looking
out for your girls because what is worse
than spending time and money scouring
the internet for your next purchase only
to later find out that you are scammed
with eBay authenticity guarantee you'll
never get faked over again the service
currently covers eligible items across
sneakers watches handbags jewelry and
streetwear personally we feel more
confident in ordering online because we
know that an expert at eBay is
authenticating our items so any purchase
that is backed by the authenticity
guarantee is sent to the authentication
team who personally inspect it they
check it against the listing and they
authenticate it so as any good Real
Housewife would say in a world full of
fakes it's time to get real with eBay
authenticity guarantee you know if
you're spending time money energy all
these things on finding something that
you love make sure you're taking the
proper steps to protect it ensure your
next purchase is the real deal with eBay
authenticity guaranteed everyone
deserves real visit ebay.com for terms
today's episode is also brought to you
by Legacy box Legacy box is hands down
the brand that we get the most questions
about I feel like you guys know about it
and then you find yourself at a place in
your life where you need it and you
can't remember our code so listen up
girls do you know where your box of old
home movies is have you checked that box
in a while to make sure they're not too
damp or hot or even molding all of our
old media can break down over time and
if it's not preserved it will be lost
forever so I'm sure you're thinking like
it's fine it's in my cellar it's in my
attic I'll take care of it well the more
time you leave the more risk you run of
having your old memories be destroyed we
grew up Jack and I in the VHS era we had
a huge basement storage filled of vhs's
and we tried so many things to try and
get them to play on like our DVD player
it was so treacherous and then Legacy
box came and changed our lives so it is
easy you basically load the Legacy box
with all of your old tapes films
pictures and then you send it back
you'll get it back on a thumb drive or
the cloud it'll be ready to watch and
super easy to share it's so simple it's
basically like magic so send it in fill
it up with whatever you got they do it
all VHS camcorder pictures whatever you
need converted they will handle it their
team does it uh in the USA so you'll get
it back on a thumb drive or the cloud
what I love about uh Legacy box is that
they keep you updated along the way it's
very scary to send something so
meaningful in the mail and not know
where it is they're sending you updates
via email throughout the entire process
so you can feel really calm cool and
collected about the whole thing so don't
let the summer heat age your video tapes
your film reels and fade your photos
visit legacybox.com toast to shop their
nine dollar tape sale that's
legacybox.com toast to unlock this
incredible offer are you ready for our
next story it's a little more strike
news different strike okay
has released the names of celebrities
who have donated over one million
dollars to the campaign for struggling
actors I saw this was incredible and it
harks on something we've spoke about
earlier in the week yes so sag aftra has
put forth a list of all the celebrities
who have donated over a million dollars
and here they are Georgia namal Clooney
Dwayne The Rock Johnson Meryl Streep
then also Jennifer Lopez and Ben Affleck
Oprah Winfrey Julia Roberts Matt and
Luciana Damon Leonardo DiCaprio Hugh
Jackman and Deborah Lee Furness his wife
Ryan Reynolds and Blake Lively Nicole
Kidman and Arnold Schwarzenegger have
also donated to the huge sum yeah so we
were talking about earlier like there's
been like weird public pressure on
celebrities who haven't been seen out
picketing
um and there are more than one way there
is more than one way to support the
strike and I actually think this is huge
you know they sag has like a a like a
non-profit like a fund that helps when
we think of actors like we think of the
people on that list but there's like a
hundred thousand people in the union who
are unknown who don't make a lot of
money who actually don't even qualify
for health insurance so this fund so how
many people were on that list at least
10 they said over a million so let's say
minimum there's 10 million dollars now
that can be given to people to pay their
rent yeah so how does it work I mean I'm
sure neither you nor I know but like
does to then they divide that by the
number of members in the SAG and they
give a little bit to everyone I feel
like you apply and they like go through
the applications I honestly don't know
got it well I'm sure it's based on like
who situation is most dire yeah
but they seem organized over at sag like
they got they got a system for it and
that's huge yeah that is huge and
because these are these are working
actors who don't make a lot of money and
who for the foreseeable future can't
make any right right I've also been um I
saw Tick Tock yesterday Greer grammar
she's not like the perfect person to
have done it because she is technically
an EPO baby but she did like an unboxing
she's like I just got my residuals in
from sag they sent me a check for like
she was on awkward she's been in a bunch
of movies and here are the residuals I
got and she's like a decently well-known
actress and toaster actually hey Greer
um and she was reading her that most of
most of the residuals that came in they
were like checks from Awkward
it was literally like 11 cents I think
the most one was like a dollar sixty
cents so then the actors are striking
for residuals on streaming platforms
yeah but the residuals aren't great if
you're not on friends no they're they
want a better they're negotiating like a
better deal
is Awkward on the streaming platform I'm
sure it's on Paramount plus because
right now they get no residuals from
streaming
maybe that residual is from cable right
so they they get no residuals from
streaming but they want to negotiate
four residuals but we see that actually
residuals are not
what we think they are no but they could
be a lot better I think most people are
watching those binging those shows on
streamers like that's for like a rerun
yeah on cable which nobody watches
but cables but Cable's the one that
actually has a profitable residual
system I do believe that they're also
negotiating for like a better
uh split on on all
residuals got it
because it's like still this model from
like the 1900s well maybe if your theory
is correct by the time we're back for
maternity leave it'll be September and
you said that's when the strike will end
so maybe that's just what people in the
industry I know that's just like what
they said that's what the Insiders are
saying or tick tock or no insiders like
people who might know in my personal
life like not anything on social media
but again like as always take everything
I say with half a grain of salt and are
the Insiders that you know on the SAG
side or on the business side
business
um
kind of
I don't wanna I don't want to say too
much you know about my sources
it was literally just like one person
who like works in the industry like I
need to calm down no no you have really
he made a fire point he made other
sources in high places Claude
unbelievable
are you ready for our next story yeah a
little exciting doll news Kylie Jenner
launches her own Bratz doll
Kylie has teamed up with a toy company
Bratz to release their first ever
celebrity doll collaboration on Tuesday
the brand launched six mini Kylie dolls
it's called the mini Bratz X Kylie
Collectibles that recreates some of
Kylie's most iconic fashion looks
including two of her Met Gala outfits
then Kylie shared a cute clip of her
daughter stormy wearing a tool dress and
playing with the dolls on her Instagram
story she said had to get storm all of
the minis at Bratz I feel like this is
that Kylie taking her power back I feel
like people used to like say as an
insult she looks like a Bratz doll yeah
that will just never be an insult to me
Brad cells are quite literally snatched
to the gods and I would love to look
like one literally goals yeah they're
all gorgeous yeah they're so cute
they're so stylish they're so pretty
they say that about Ari too
do they yeah I mean she does look like a
garage sale just because she's so tiny
tiny also the way that Ari is like
going through I know like her own
cancellation Scandal right now and also
all this like old stuff is coming back
up like the donuts video yeah I know
I've been seeing that all over everyone
had
um forgotten repressed
that was like an incredibly weird thing
that she did like I If you don't know
the video just Google it she like went
into like a mom and pop donut shop and
when the person behind the counter went
like back to the kitchen she started
licking all the donuts on display yeah
no and then talking about how much she
hates America yeah because it's like a
like a big fat thing that Americans do
is happening like this it's delicious
and she's literally supporting that
institution so it makes no sense yeah no
she was being
like a reckless teen I think we all
chalked it up and it was like people are
entitled to like their bad moments like
it was a terrible thing but like what
should we do it kill her like
it was just dumb teenage Antics
Rebellion phase she wasn't a teenager
but
yeah we had moved on but now everything
everything was coming back yeah she's
going through it it's not her moment and
like her relationship timelines with Big
Sean and David Davidson so she's clearly
like a girly who just like overlaps
yeah
but Ethan what's his name Slater is that
his last name yeah back to Kylie I think
this is so cute the dolls are so cute I
have no use for them but if I did that
was my question like who is this for
because Bratz dolls like are for kids
yeah Kylie's fans are like grown ass
women maybe it's just like a collectible
thing or it's for
just girl like girls like Kylie also you
could say the exact same thing about the
Barbie movie
yeah but then once you see it like you
realize it's for adults
yeah okay so the dolls are for kids
I don't know
I if I had a daughter I would get these
yeah it's cute it's so cute
I saw someone message me or I saw a
tweet that was like the Bratz movie
walked so Barbie could run
the Bratz movie I'm so glad you brought
that up was a transformative piece of
Cinema
and the Bratz movie is so good you want
to know how I know the rats movie's so
good
hmm
do you know what film we were all
watching of course we found out that our
every everyone knows the toasters know
oh okay should I finish the story or no
you can but when we told the original
story honestly it's worth I remember the
episode we were in La we were it was a
long time ago La week smidge was there
I think it was like the Thursday or
Friday episode and it was because we
were doing um ads for attitude
that was a really long time ago so you
can go watch it but just brief Cliff
Notes uh when we were all like in middle
and high school we found out that our
dad passed away we were literally
sitting on the couch watching the Bratz
movie and our mom came in I was like
pause the TV early I got some news and
the movie was so good like that is
something that would like ruin a film
you know finding out your parent died
um but I love that movie still like it's
not even destroyed like that's how good
the movie is it transcends death and
grief yeah kind of like the toast I was
just that's the thread that's the thread
yeah
um no the movie is so good I would watch
it today it's a masterpiece I don't
think it got the recognition that it
deserved and we're always quoting it
like don't get your bragas in a Twist oh
and the I feel like now we're having I'm
having Deja Vu like of the repetition
but what's so great about the movie is
that like the main Bratz character her
mom is that Queen I believe it's the
actress I forget her name she plays the
mother in My Big Fat Greek Wedding she's
a Timeless Queen no it's a star said
movie
is layered as well yeah if you haven't
seen it you need to see it and it's very
inclusive there's a deaf main character
it's amazing yeah
really amazing and I'm glad that Kylie's
partnered with them to give them the
visibility they deserve yeah maybe like
this partnership Rising Tides raise All
Ships like maybe now more people will be
invested in Brat's culture and watch you
know the Bratz live action movie and
more people will see that stunning work
of art yeah it's all good a girl a girl
can dream
again he's definitely sick
get well soon we're
foolishly Mom I love are you ready for
our fifth and final story I am it's some
exciting Broadway news because the
notebook the musical will be opening on
Broadway in Spring 2024 the musical
adaptation of Nicholas Sparks says the
notebook is officially heading to
Broadway performances will begin in
February 2024 with the show's opening
night set for March 14th the cast has
yet to be announced but the notebook
features music and lyrics by Broadway
Alum Ingrid Michaelson and a bunch of
other Broadway Heavy Hitters working on
it as well the notebook musical was
originally announced in 2019 and ran at
the Chicago Shakespeare theater in the
fall of 2022. so it's been done and then
I was scrolling through the article and
there's already a song that's on YouTube
by Ingrid Michaelson called if if this
is love and it's a notebook Musical song
okay I mean I have to see it before I
can judge it does sound like a little
crazy like
it's very Camp it's very Camp
um I just feel like we got the musical
version
of the notebook and it was Miley Cyrus's
Nicholas Sparks you know so social movie
called uh the last song
when the waves are blood in the shore
and I can't find my way home anymore
that was like literally Miley's best
song ever she needs to cover that again
I feel like she's always going back and
doing like seven things in the climb
like give us that no I agree I'm always
singing that song weirdly it's like so
beautiful it's so beautiful and I do
agree if there was going to be a
Nicholas Sparks Broadway show like why
not the last song that already that
already has original music right like
give us Miley now
I think that this could be good
so underrated Miley was in a Nicholas
Sparks film you know it's under not even
that that's where she met Liam Hemsworth
they fell in love they got married they
got broken up they got together again
the Nicholas Sparks Miley Cyrus film is
almost a perfect film
why is it imperfect you know why Jackie
I don't know one scene that's like butt
clenchingly cringe what scene
they're in the truck like driving around
did this go viral
I don't think so oh we like always like
as kids were just like cringe why what
were they doing
she starts singing She Will Be Loved and
like she literally sounds terrible yeah
yeah agreed she's like looking out the
window and she starts singing to the
radio and he's like wow like your voice
is really good and like is that just
like a cringy Trope but like her voice
actually sounded like terrible and she
actually has a good voice right like
there was no reason why they couldn't
have just done another take or like put
the song in her K the last time I
watched the last song was a few years
ago I sobbed my eyes out yeah it's got
it all it's got love it's got tragedy
it's got you know classism yeah oh my
God it really it was emotional for me
no it's it's an amazing movie it is so
maybe if the notebook on Broadway does
well
they would consider the last song on
Broadway I can't I don't know why I keep
forgetting the name of the movie I keep
thinking when I look at you is the name
of the movie but that's the name of the
song Miley wrote yeah the last song
the last song Why did Nicholas Sparks
like stop
film filmmaking like I feel like there
was Dear John The Notebook when I look
at what's it called the last song there
was like a couple of years where it was
like Peak entertainment and then it just
kind of died off
well I feel like Letters to Juliet that
genre has sort of yeah not a place to go
anymore you know it's like Colleen
Hoover is the new Nicholas Sparks
writing wise yeah but let's see how her
movies do so far it's not looking good
it's so true
um
I'm sure there's like an actual reason
why Nicholas Sparks it hasn't made a lot
of movies since but
if it was his scandal no I don't he had
a very short-lived Scandal about like a
school he created yeah and like
anti-Semitism yeah yeah we gotta look
into that I know I've tried I I can't
wrap my head around it was such a
bizarre story with like no context yeah
I actually don't think it impacted his
career because it was like such a weird
story but like maybe he's also just
writing less like maybe he's enjoying
the fruits of his labor retirement
yeah perhaps but his movie's like if he
made movies now but they would go to
Netflix we'd all watch him in one day
and I mean right like it just they don't
have
he was definitely ahead of his time yeah
he gave us everything he could it's true
and you know he gave us quite a lot
including
when the waves
uh the blood in the show wasn't there
weren't there more
um songs from that EP
I don't think so I thought it was just a
single that she released for the film no
let me just go to this album really
quickly
yeah I'm going on Spotify oh it's an EP
and that song is on it but the rest of
the songs are not from the movie
got it
but it's a great idea it slaps
slaps slapio
so those are the stories that you needed
to know oh
she's a Rhymer um so yeah that's our
episode tomorrow's episode reminders our
final episode before Jax heads off to
maternity leave so send her your well
wishes I wish you well thank you so much
for listening to the toaster Millennium
Morning Show where we deliver the fast
five stories that you need to know every
Monday through Friday so if you're
watching this on YouTube no everybody
I'm keep [__] this up every Monday
through Friday on YouTube so you're
watching this on YouTube please feel
free to subscribing give this video a
thumbs up also available podcast
find us that does live with five star
review about a beautiful stunning in
wickedly talented we are have an amazing
day you guys and we'll see you tomorrow
for Friday I love you bye